I feel so like confident and like sexy
the Emmy award-winning Netflix show
queer eye offers more than just
makeovers and home renovations fans
rallied around just Guilbeau after a
recent episode when they learned she was
forced to drop out of college because
she could not afford it
CBS this morning Saturday co-host
Michelle Miller is here with how the
show changed Gil Bo's life and how she
is now paying it forward Michelle now
this is all about the power of
television right good morning before she
amassed more than 67,000 followers on
Instagram Jess Guilbeau spoke openly on
queer I about being estranged from her
family after she revealed that she was
gay she said it left her financially
unable to pursue her dreams of getting a
college degree that is until now
so I'm mission this week guys is to take
jess from feeling rejected to bully
except when the cast from queer I
arrived at Jess Gill Beau's home she was
ready for the fab 5 treatment the
evaluation of how she lived this your
closet how she dressed Joe coming here
and how she looked but the five men who
can easily pick you apart
she beaten a bed frame - she needs a bed
frame are really there to help put
yourself together it wouldn't be easy
for Guilbeau I'm when she came out as a
lesbian at 16 her adoptive parents
kicked her out of the house I was hoping
that they would realize hey that's my
kid so of course I'm gonna love them you
know despite no family support Guilbeau
eventually made it to the University of
Kansas to study computer science two
years sandwiches but the pressure of
going to school and earning a living
collided and left her with little choice
College was a different ballgame but
supporting myself at that time was just
doing what I needed to do you know there
wasn't any other option it was in there
that or not survive grab a nice big
handful while Gilda learned to fend for
herself
her family's faded from her life another
way to find out a lot about your family
is from your family queer I reunited her
with her sister Janice and the niece she
never met connecting with her has just
been my favorite part because she has
just become such like a huge piece of my
foundation and my support system after
her transformation like cute and
confident she just be black and be gay
came the tears the hugs and a wave of
online support including a message from
grammy-nominated artist Janelle Monae
who called Guilbeau her personal hero
I'm inspired by hurts like your heroes
inspired by you like what else can you
ask for at that point and though she
never asked for it a queer I fan
launched a GoFundMe page to sing
Guilbeau back to school
it's reached nearly a hundred thousand
dollars I never thought that going back
to school would be something that I
could ever do just because I was
drowning it dead and I haven't gone back
to school but I have paid off my student
loans and all my debts and so I plan to
go back really really really really soon
the fact you had a goal and you've
achieved it is great after hearing the
news queer eyes tan France sent this
message have the best time at college be
sure to study very very hard however I
want you to play hard too I want you to
use this experience to build that friend
group to build up chosen family whatever
money Gilberg doesn't need for her
education will be donated to GLAAD an
organization formed to accelerate
acceptance of the LGBTQ community really
excited to go to school but I'm also
like really excited it's like giving
back because I've never been in a
position where I've been I'm open to
that she's excited to give back well
Jess Gilboa plans to use that computer
science degree to code program or even
create video games one day we are so
excited for her and I especially love
what she said which she tweeted out
asking for help is not a sign of
weakness it is a sign of strength she's
right about that I like when she said
it's really cool when you're your hero
is inspired by you
Dena mone would
yes courage community family Michelle
thank you so very much